why don't you drink alcohol right before  I turned 18 my dad warned me and he said  your grandpa was an alcoholic because he  was a prisoner of war in World War II he  said we have very addictive  personalities he just recommended to me  that I don't drink too much  and I just I just didn't I listened to  that I guess that prisoner of war thing  really affected your grandpa dude okay  so he was in a Japanese prison in the  Philippines for the entirety of World  War II yeah Bataan Death March he was a  part of that he did not talk about it  until he was in his 80s they fed him  like wet rice he he said that he had to  eat rats and how you you guys know how  they got out I think is crazy one day an  American walked up to his cell and  opened it and the guy said War's over  and he got to go home so my respect for  him went through the roof you know I  didn't blame the guy for drinking a  little bit he was he was always a good  person